brand-new poll that show that more and
more Americans are rethinking what
happened on 9/11 and increasingly more
people are saying they do not believe
the government's version of events
[Music]
greetings apiece welcome to the D she'll
subscribe if you haven't already now
it's a very sad reality that whenever
9/11 is mentioned somehow Islam and
Muslims has to get brought up or people
in the back of their mind you're
thinking okay Islam had something to do
with it
motivating Muslims hell no when you
study and this is what really triggered
me to really get out there and try to
educate people on the purpose of life on
Islam and all clear these misconceptions
because the more I started to study
Islam I saw that it promoted peace
justice love and mercy all of the
opposite things that many of these
radical hate fear-mongering individuals
who are out there spewing this crazy
stuff to have nothing to do with Islam
but now they're over look check it out
my next guest he goes even further and
says Muslims had nothing to do at 9/11
and candidly wouldn't only fringe people
still question what happened on 9/11
well perhaps not today we're gonna
release to you results of a brand new
poll that show that more and more
Americans are rethinking what happened
on 9/11 along with three get this
Plus architects and engineers and 911
family members now there are more than
1500 architects and engineers who say
that it could not have been brought down
by office fires they are backed by 911
family members who are calling for an
independent unbiased investigation
that's we're gonna be talking about this
week's show now my question is to you is
it is it wrong to ask questions and want
answers to these questions that's all
we're gonna be talking about on this
week's exciting show don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
[Music]
this is the Enver Masood peace be with
you how are you sir thank you peace be
with you too you have dedicated your
whole life to this cause well at least
since 1990 since 1990 you've dedicated
the majority of your time you put
everything almost on the line I mean
this is to go against the grain yeah I
was fully employed at a salaried
engineer had an excellent job I have
quit that to go into consulting and
because of my outspokenness the
consulting opportunities became fewer so
since 1990 till about the present this
is what I've been knowing what's the
first thing that you will say to someone
who will say that people who are asking
questions about this are crazy and
deranged have you ever been confronted
like this oh yeah the first thing I get
is it's a conspiracy theorist the
definition of a conspiracy is when two
or more people acting in concert
knowingly commit an offense or E or or a
crime all right misdemeanor or felony an
offense that is the definition of a
conspiracy was Miss a conspiracy
absolutely yes it was and most people
need to go to jail for treason are you
know because I don't have a conspiracy
theory the government does the
government's are counter 9/11 is itself
a conspiracy theory the only problem
with that is the facts don't support the
government's theory I have facts that
contradict that and I've challenged the
chairman of the 9/11 Commission
personally and 9/11 Commission lied to
the public I mean you cannot be that
stupid you cannot be that stupid
now do we going back to the since you
mentioned the Commission weren't there
people like Lee Hamm
who was the head of the Commission who
said that this was set up from the
beginning to fail so there all kinds of
reasons we thought we were set up to
fail we got started late we had a very
short time frame indeed we had to get it
extended we did not have enough money
they were faith and they were afraid we
were going to hang somebody that we
would point the finger Lee and I write
in a book that we think the Commission
in many ways was set up to fail because
we had not enough money we didn't have
enough time we had been appointed by the
most partisan people in Washington yes
they've written that it was set up to
fail
and there's another commissioner or I
forget his name from Georgia who
resigned saying it's a scam uh-huh
have you talked to the 9/11 family
members I'm a family member trying to
find out the answers to the murder of
three thousand-plus people
the bottom line is that it needs to be
investigated properly
please look architects and engineers
people all around the world scientists
all around the world are questioning
this and there's some deep deep
explaining to do
we will never heal this country will
never ever ever forget that day we have
to demand a new investigation I want
justice here
and others there's some like what is it
now three thousand-plus scientists
engineers architects who are asking
questions also
it took some kind of
consciousness-raising on my part before
I was willing to look at the the
possibilities and really you need to go
where the evidence leads as an engineer
I have three degrees in engineering I
signed that petition for architects and
engineers for 9/11 truth some time ago
because the American people absolutely
need the truth of 9/11 look at the
evidence in fact I'll say this very
categorically any reasonable person who
looks at the evidence has been brought
forward that's got to come away with the
feeling that something has to be done a
real investigation has to be put forward
Oh what the truth yes 3000 M yeah I've
actually appeared on one talk with
Richard gage architects and engineers at
another with one of the members of
pilots for 9/11 truth who is military
pilot and we have no disagreement
although I must say Richard gage does
not talk about the Pentagon I do what
motivates motivated you to dedicate so
much time to this well one I did have
time between consulting assignments
second I'm an engineer who was always
curious about big multidisciplinary
problems the first problem was that when
I was working at Oklahoma Gas Electric
hey I want to go into details but I
solved that then at the Department of
Energy I managed the u.s. national power
grid study I had 26 teams 150 love this
disciplinary folks working on it so I
always enjoyed large multidisciplinary
problems and I didn't approach this to
solve 9/11 it just turned out that I
uncovered one thing which led to
something else in over 78 years I wrote
this book what are you trying to
accomplish just get to the truth without
truth there's no justice and without
justice there is no peace one thing I
can say for sure without a shadow of a
doubt
that because Islam has somehow been
brought into this so this is what we as
Muslims take strong exception to Islam
doesn't condone but it condemns acts
likes this this is was a sad and tragic
incident this has nothing to do with
Islam but now we're going even deeper
you're saying that hold on
you know because somehow they've also
said and Muslims we have to take
accountability let's say that there are
some deranged Muslims out there some
people who are not practicing Islam
properly so you have a fringe element
but now you're going on top of that and
saying look it wasn't even muslims who
did had anything to do with it yeah the
first thing let me cite one statistics
and this is from the government since
9/11 why is our news media foaming at
the mouth when it comes to stories about
Islamic terrorists but not white guy
terrorists it's not because Muslims are
a bigger threat in fact between 1980 and
2005 94 percent of all the attempted or
successful terrorist attacks on US soil
were not carried out by Islamic radicals
but instead by non-muslims mostly white
guys so then why the obsession it's
killing of innocent human beings human
life is precious so inside the US
they're more most Americans killed by
non-muslims in this country yes all of
the Christians everyday people walk into
post off I mean people walk into post
offices they walk into schools that's
what Columbine is I mean I could do this
all day long there's so there are so
many more examples of Christians and I
happen to be a Christian that's back to
this notion of you're idealizing
Christianity in my mind to my read
there's so many more examples a yawn of
Christians who do that then you could
ever give me examples of Muslims who
have done it inside this country where
you live work Muslims there are more
Americans killed by bathtub accidents
and dear these drinks bee stings
so of course there
Muslims that are doing all kinds of
horrible acts but many of them aren't
inspired by the US or actually
cultivated by the u.s. are you aware
that the Taliban when the US was still
in there fighting Russians they sent
textbooks to the to Afghanistan where
the ABC that you're used to with a for
Apple B for something banana was
replaced by all weapons and ammunition
and those textbooks were prepared here
in the US and sent to Afghanistan so
much of the violence it's not to say
there was never violence but much of it
has been exacerbated by the policy of
the West there's a a fireman right now
that we're gonna take a clip and show as
I said I had 32 years there and I was
also a trained fire marshal a fire
marshal is considered an expert witness
in court he's like a forensic detective
he has the power to administer the oath
take testimony in issue a subpoena
that's a lot of power it was there was
an explosion the building did come down
in complete classical controlled
demolition it came down on its own
footprint there's no question about that
as a matter of fact richard gage from
architects and engineers has completely
handled that from his area of expertise
never in the history of a world never in
the history of high-rise skyscrapers has
ever a skyscraper ever come down because
of fire and I'm talking massive fire and
you know the reason why because fire
does not burn by itself hot enough to
compromise and melt steel what we had in
the World Trade Center and I saw myself
was molten lava like pockets of molten
steel all right I spent the night on the
pile searching for bodies and I saw that
with my own eyes so who are you going to
believe are you gonna believe a bunch of
government bureaucrats or my fellow
rubbers which I lost 343 guys that day
this fireman that the people who just
got to seize one of the head fireman's I
don't know how many years he's been on
the job and there's many like him
he's saying that this was a controlled
demolition well yeah I'm no demolition
expert but just as an engineer seeing
how the building's coming you are also
as a certified engineer yeah I'll have
electrical industrial engineering
degrees there's no way that building can
collapse like that without explosives of
some kind
the plane hit somewhat about two-thirds
the way up on tower the towers you would
expect some part of the towers to fall
off all off but you wouldn't expect a
sudden collapse the symmetric collapse
and you wouldn't expect the building
below the point of impact collapse hold
it right there we're gonna take a break
that's the first question that I'm sure
people are asking how if who caused this
now that you needed to demo the place
that means that it would have to be set
up prior thank you very much so that's
the first question and you got a lot
more we're gonna be right back with more
with Anne Verma sudhir on the Dean show
don't know anywhere subscribe right now
[Music]
back here on the DS show first question
could we say safe to say who set up the
demo well we don't know we know they're
there the buildings were the security
systems had been turned off for some
time prior to 9/11 that folks were
coming in and out of the building and
that others don't know who they were
so somebody set up the explosives we
don't know who did it how about there is
an interesting Hispanic gentleman
William Rodriguez a janitor in the twin
towers for almost 20 years and 9/11
survivor who saved hundreds of lives on
September 11th by a locking door after
door for firefighters and dragging out
at least a dozen people with his own
bare hands
known as the last man out before the
World Trade Center collapsed his
unlikely story had the media glued to
him like bees to honey who was the
janitor have you met him Roderick
correspondent with him Rodriguez yes he
was he wasn't many were awards and he
was with was it Clinton Clinton that
must have been quite an honor for you it
was an experience definitely and at that
time I was basically loaded to go into
politics because they said this is the
guy that we need to get the Latino vote
and I was playing the whole game of
politics because I was doing the
activism and on to the moment that I
started to ask questions about what
really happened on 9/11 and you may
remember the whole thing about the 9/11
Commission to be forum and basically
became very active to get it basically
started and what a surprise I was one of
the persons that testified for the 9/11
Commission my testimony doesn't appear
on the final report and they were
honoring him and whatnot Bush honored
Bush honored him but didn't somehow the
story took a twist no longer sweetheart
of American broadcasts William now talks
mostly to foreign outlets the reason his
version of 9/11 differed from the
official scenario it was the first
hijacked plane no hello that was an
explosion before night before the plane
hit the tower well he was like the last
survivor who he was the last survivor he
was in the he says basement b1
when he heard a loud explosion but it
was below him
and he thought the generator had blown
up and then a few seconds later he heard
he describes a loud bang at the top so
apparently before whatever struck the
top of the tower there had been an
explosion below him and yes I we've
corresponded I don't know that he's
changed the story at all
no so that's the first thing and then
you have also let's go back to these how
many is it now of architects and
engineers for 9/11 truth architects and
engineers who say that it could not have
been brought down by office fires they
are backed by 9/11 family members who
are calling for an independent unbiased
investigation scientifically you know
this is not possible
the their scientists their engineers as
an engineer I have three degrees in
engineering I signed that petition for
architects and engineers for 9/11 truth
some time ago because the American
people absolutely need the truth of 9/11
there are pilots there military
intelligence personnel there's all kinds
of you know I've top your head some of
the names that these are big figures you
know well presidential candidates look
at the evidence in fact I'll say just
very categorically any reasonable person
who looks at the evidence there's been
brought forward has got to come away
with the feeling that something has to
be done a real investigation has to be
put forward mr. Bowman who was headed up
the so-called Star Wars program under
President Reagan he questioned that he
was a presidential candidate in a few
years ago Wesley Clark whom I met and I
actually handed in this book met him at
George Washington joint sue Georgetown
University
he questions what happened so the
Richard gage of architects and engineers
it's large group there's Balsamo of the
pilots for 9/11
they all question that I've correspond
with all of these people how about the
the the people who have lost loved ones
the family members I'm a family member
trying to find out the answers to the
murder of three thousand plus people
these architects and engineers people
all around the world scientists all
around the world are questioning this we
will never heal this country will never
ever ever forget that day we have to
demand a new investigation I want
justice here are they a part of this
questioning also video they are and but
it's so hard to get hold of them it's
their their names aren't really
available I don't have therefore I've
tried to get home with them to find out
what happened to their loved ones what
bodies were recovered where they were
buried because there's apparently some
uncertainty about all of that
when specially when you get to examining
what happened with the plane allegedly
to obstruct the Pentagon and the one
that alleged to have crashed in that
field in Pennsylvania the evidence shows
that at the Pentagon there is no
evidence of a Boeing 757 crashing there
I am
Major General Albert Stubblebine
I am retired Army Major General in my
last assignment Alaska man I was
responsible for all of the Army's
strategic intelligence forces around the
world on September 11 in 2001 what hit
the Pentagon I don't know exactly what
hit it but I do know from the
photographs that I have analyzed and
looked at very very carefully it was not
an airplane in the field in Pennsylvania
whatever was fell there was blown out of
the sky did not impact the earth with
that story about the power passenger
struggling with the hijacker that's all
false hmm seems like Geraldo you know
Geraldo he had a change of he's a famous
yeah he's someone after he listened to
some of the family members and the chief
of architects and engineers he had a
change of heart more than 13-hundred
architects and engineers examine the
evidence about building seventh collapse
and disagree with the official report
issued by the National Institute of
Standards and Technology
I certainly am much more open-minded
about it than I was and it is because of
the involvement of the 9/11 families and
all these engineers and architects yeah
Geraldo I saw one YouTube video where he
changed his mind about it the the
biggest I think the one name we haven't
mentioned is Professor David Ray Griffin
professor David Ray Griffin was a
retired theologian from a California
University and a philosopher and he had
written 1215 books on philosophy and
theology he came across the so called
conspiracy theorist it was very
skeptical but eventually he looked into
it and ended up writing 1213 books on
9/11 he 1213 books so he started off as
a skeptic he wouldn't relieve any of
this and probably was calling people go
crazy and deranged yeah and you now he's
writing about global warming into the
environment but I mean if you want the
person that's done I think the best
research and written the most but is
they
different have things like this in the
past happen you have like was a point
1864 the gulf of tonkin and yeah it's
very common for partner major powers to
lie to their people to justify some
military action the gulf of tonkin where
the vietnamese were alleged to have shot
at our ships
I think the USS Maddox if I remember
correctly that was a lie because Lyndon
Johnson is quoted to have said for all I
know they were shooting at whales this
is in the archives I got this out of
there the other one more interesting or
more directly relevant is the operation
Northwoods
operation Northwoods was a plan proposed
by the Joint Chiefs of Staff to
President Kennedy and what they said we
will shoot Americans on the streets here
we will fly a plane with Americans
towards Cuba substituted for an unmanned
plane and shoot down and blame Cuba so
that they would have an excuse to attack
Cuba and make war and Castro so this is
very common the Pearl Harbor some say
was elf well it wasn't a false flag but
the president knew it was coming and let
it happen so they could join the war
against Japan right who benefits at the
end if you look at motive we don't have
to bring on Sherlock Holmes to come in
and look because obviously this goes
against the teachings of Islam this has
nothing to do with Islam you actually
can buy yourself a one-way ticket to the
Hellfire by killing one innocent human
being you know Islam is clear on this
you have no justification in Islam and
that's why when we look at as Muslims
those who are trying to live in peace
with society with our Creator and this
has only brought more harm to Islam and
Muslims there's no benefit therefore for
for Islam or Muslims but who really at
the end benefits well at the end the
folks that benefit is the
military-industrial Congressional
complex now the so-called homeland
security complex
these are the guys benefiting they've
been benefitting for years President
Eisenhower warned against the
military-industrial complex before him
there was a general Smedley Butler who
received two congressional medals of
Honor like Audie Murphy when a lot of
folks know about Audie Murphy but they
don't know about steadily Butler because
he talked about the real purpose of
their wars in South America and China so
this has been going on which comes which
brings us to the real election today
none of the things that candidates are
promising to the American people as
opposed to the corporations can be
achieved unless you cut that military
budget and that's what was proposed
after the collapse of the Soviet Union
the Secretary of Defense McNamara and
his assistant secretary testified on the
hill that the defense budget can be cut
in half over ten years that's what set
off there are I guess alarm bells
through the military industrial complex
and they had to come up with a plan to
keep them and to keep the defense
spending and in fact increase it so
we're gonna take a break the main
question is now that we got one down but
there's so many more but real simple one
to remember who set up to demo the
demolition let's look we don't know we
don't know that's that's a big question
you know let's take a break when we
write back with more here on the Dean
show an independent press to try to get
the word out to the public because the
public is mesmerized by the mainstream
media and let me give you my opinion of
a mainstream media the mainstream media
is their mission is is to act as the
most effective weapon of mass deception
and public manipulation the world has
ever seen and if you don't think that so
ask anyone any taboo question that the
mainstream media frowns upon with its
army of trusted celebrity Presta toots
all right and and and you will see a
sadly predictable knee-jerk reaction
Airi response
from the public because that's what
they've been trained to believe and
trust in subscribe right now
[Music]
back here on the Dean show with the
author of 9/11 unveiled how many people
get this for free said I was free just
just Google 9/11 unveiled free and
you'll get to it how many downloads over
75 over 75,000 okay now let me ask you
this the war on Islam you you what why
did you label the book of the world well
this book started out as just separate
articles and the first article was as we
were attacking Iraq the first time and I
wrote that article as the bombs were
falling and it was the Holocaust in Iraq
is what their title was and I continued
writing it at some point I so someone
suggested why don't you put this into a
book so I did and I thought of a catchy
title the titles if they're long I
couldn't write the war for resources
markets etc so it was the war in Islam I
mean is that really what we see going on
today does I'm not most mister you're
like well actually for some it is a war
on Islam but for the most part it's a
war for resources and markets and that's
what virtually every war wheat in
America's fought or the war is fought by
other countries it's typically there for
access to resources and markets or
rather to control them we don't
necessarily need the oil we want to
control the oil just like the drug
dealer doesn't need the drugs he wants
to control the drugs and that's what
virtually every war is about control of
resources and markets have you sat with
some of these big officials that
question the official story have you
talked with them have you tried to none
of them will I was at a small gathering
where the chairman of the 9/11
Commission The Wall Street Rapporteur on
terrorism a british expert on terrorism
they were sitting as close as your
cameras for me and i at the end i of the
live there talk i rose up and i said mr.
chairman are you aware that three
thousand-plus architects and engineers
questioned their official account of
9/11 and I have a little book
summarizing whatever my research
and I said I'd like you to rebut it and
he said well I'll get back to you later
which is reasonable I didn't expect him
to room but none of them ever will get
back to you
they say that so that they have
something in front of the audience like
there will agreeing to respond to you
but they don't in South Africa when I
was in like three weeks lecture toward
giving two or three talks daily from
audiences of a hundred to a thousand the
national radio station would not put
beyond till somebody from the embassy
was there to rebut me but they waited
and waited eventually put me on because
nobody would come forward now are you
willing if somebody have you had debates
with anybody about this and are you
willing if someone invited you to go on
I live long enough a anybody from the
administration to be a spokesman for the
administration account for 9/11 and I
will rebut it but what we have here if
you were to look at that event as a
criminal act you know in a criminal act
if you do not unable to rebut the
evidence presented then you lose the
case right away no I'm sorry go ahead
yeah I think that's called prima facie
evidence so we have prima facie evidence
of muslims innocence and since the
government refuses we heard about it
under American law they would be off as
innocent what if someone says okay
because I mean this is profound let's go
back again 3,000 if we were saying just
3,000 laymen but these are 3,000
architects and engineers who have
scientific forensic evidence you know
these are the experts in that area why
the official story the final official
account of 9/11 is unscientific and
false and I in that book gave a massive
amount of evidence that's been compiled
by scientists architects and engineers
that all three buildings although in
that book I focus on World Trade Center
seven were brought down by explosives
there's simply no other possibility and
the only way that NIST
the National Institute of Standards and
Technology which wrote the official
report the only way they were able to
deny that was to commit massive
scientific fraud it's in simple words
simply means they lied they lied and
they lied
I think it's unprecedented in America to
have so many professional claiming that
the official account is not wrong in the
media not doing anything
complex by demolition experts not doing
anything about it but it's
understandable because 90% of what you
see watch listen to or read is
controlled by six corporations in
America they control all that that's why
and they're the same ones they're
benefiting from the wars so you don't
expect them to undercut their own store
source of income that's interesting okay
so you have on one end you have a group
of people benefiting so many people just
they don't want to go against the grain
it's understandable date they're quiet
but over here on the other side these
people most people who are coming
forward they're getting the ones who are
going to get ridiculed they got more to
lose where you know so many of them are
risking their employment to do that but
those are the people worth listening to
right right and many of them are retired
but the ones that are risking their
employment I haven't really found the
ones that are risking their employment
I've I think most of the ones I've
spoken with are retired and I'm retired
but while I was on I was approached by
the news and I I deferred from
commenting hmm so but regardless I mean
you have that many professionals
disagreeing if you get some other issue
you have six professional or two
professional
agree in there on TV take any issue
regarding Israel you see a handful of
people protesting in the media is
covering it and you'll have thousands of
Muslims demonstrating in Washington the
media doesn't cover it so that's just
the media selectivity now the people who
also I mean their motive you look
forward they they're really there
there's no motive but at the end truth
they want the truth - they want these
questions answered the architects and
engineers the experts in this field for
me there's a great personal satisfaction
to have completed some kind of
investigation and the reception it's
gotten from the public you know do you
work at the time I do so now that you
see it what does that story mean to you
as evidenced by the downloads and
talking as if assignments etc for me
there was that great personal
satisfaction to be able to contribute on
this major issue I have nothing to gain
by it I set up the wisdom phone in 1995
to try to get the truth out about Islam
yeah I draw a salary a $1 a year from
that who is the fund so I definitely
don't benefit but the personal
satisfaction is priceless yeah that's
something people really can understand
when you when you gives you confidence
when you when you have truth on your
side evidence on your side there's some
some major confidence that it builds is
that right yeah and just the little
notes I get from around the world of
appreciation and it just makes it all
work give us we're almost out of time
maybe your top three questions that you
would ask somebody an authority that you
want answers to you don't have toss of
the answer but from your investigation
and what maybe these 3,000 architects
and engineers give us one two three top
questions we answered what asking one
who set up the demolition that's just
fact there was a demolition setup and
firemen have testified to its scientists
our engineers architects that's
unrefuted oh yeah I would say at the
Pentagon show me hard evidence that the
boy son 57 that you alleged Christ there
and that evidence would be serial
numbers on the parts etc of that plane -
you know about the World Trade Center
towers explain to me how that tower
could possibly collapse by the impact of
a plane 2/3 of the way up and the fire
which basically was out of steam within
15-20 minutes there's no way before 9/11
no steel frame high-rise had collapsed
after 9/11 honey collapse on that day
three collapse which leads me to
building seven of the World Trade Center
a forty seven story building that about
5:20 I believe in the evening came down
suddenly symmetrically how can that
possibly collapse show me a computer
model or something that'll show how that
collapsed it's impossible without
explosives so those are the main
questions and people can actually both
of your books they can download them for
free
yeah just google the title and and
through the word free and you'll get to
it and this is the war on Islam and 9/11
unveiled they can get there for free
thank you very much any closing comments
that you'd like to further for the
person who you know at the end it takes
some some go ahead one closing comment
if you're Muslim ask your Muslim
leadership to examine this issue I'd be
happy to come out there and speak on it
I'll get you other speakers closer to
you to speak on it but get with your
interfaith community and speak out on
this issue thank you very much we
started with haste we are done with
peace peace be with you peace Peter
there you have it another exciting
episode subscribe if you haven't already
remember we start out in the beginning
look I'm Muslim technically a Muslim is
one who has consciously chosen to submit
to the creator not the creation Jesus
Moses Abraham and all the messengers
that the Creator sent out of his love
they were all once who submitted to the
will of God
now when you're submitting yourself as a
Muslim any peaceful person who does this
and lives this peaceful way of life of
Islam submission to the crater not the
creation they're not committing acts of
terrorism they're not committing crimes
against humanity so from that
perspective done it's a lot of Muslims
nothing to do with such tragic events as
such now three thousand-plus architects
and engineers are asking some very
important questions like who set this up
the demo and firefighters and American
patriots and politicians who are coming
forward who have had a awakening of the
consciousness people who have looked
into us this a little bit deeper and who
are not just blindly following the
official stories they're asking
questions now it's up to you you want to
look into it further go ahead but we
just brought this information to you and
you can do whatever you want with it but
our main objective here was to once
again free Islam that when you think
about Islam you think about what I
thought about when I started to learn it
the love the mercy and the justice and
to have a new picture painted in your
mind and to free you from any clouded
vision that you might have have some
perverted vision about Muslims in Islam
because the more you study it the more
you will be free from thinking that it
had anything to do with motivating
people to do such an evil act and if you
like this program subscribe right now
follow us every week here in the D show
where you get to learn a lot of great
and interesting things
call us at
you
[Music]